tonight we take you to the Syria border
with Turkey and you'll hear from a man
who says he was injured in that recent
chemical attack in Syria of course
fountain-pen German halt tells us
international inspectors are still not
being given access to ground zero for
the fourth day in a row chemical weapons
inspectors failed to reach Duma the site
of the alleged chemical weapons attack
Russian officials have worked with the
Syrian regime we believe to sanitize the
locations of those suspected attacks and
remove incriminating evidence of
chemical weapons use the Syrian regime
has claimed that rebel gunfire kept the
inspectors back but Fox has learned that
all rebels have been bussed out of the
area ten days ago as part of a Russian
deal today hundreds more rebels gave up
their weapons elsewhere in the city
afraid of further gas attacks Fox has
also learned that the bodies of those
who died in the attack have been taken
from their graves by the regime and
doctors who treated the victims have
been detained and threatened if they
give evidence doctors are scared their
families who are stayed in the town in
town or or live in the government areas
will be under threat from the government
despite these attempts though the truth
is emerging bit by bit were able to
paint a picture of what exactly happened
in that terrible chemical attack in duma
we can't get to the site ourselves but
everyday evidence and witnesses come
across this border war with more
horrific details Fox News spoke to
someone who claims to be a survivor of
the chemical attack what I saw where
hundreds of injured bodies lying in the
corridors for some dying of gas others
by conventional weapons many faces were
discolored all red and blue white foam
came out of their mouths and noses
but despite the strong us-led military
response the Pentagon has acknowledged
that stockpiles remain they will have
the ability to conduct limited attacks
in the future as they contemplate the
dynamics of conducting those attacks
they've got to look over their shoulder
and be worried that we're looking at
them and we'll have the ability to
strike them again Syrian rebel leaders
have shown gratitude for the strikes but
said they hope the US would do more anam
yet we asked the president looks at the
region again because there is an enemy
growing strong here that is the Alliance
of Iran and Russia but I've spoken to
rebel commanders in the north of Syria
today who tell me that Americans have
been there and have taken blood and
urine samples from survivors of the
chemical attack and that means that
while the UN and the OPCW may not have
samples the American government does
Brett
Benjamin Hall along the border with
Syria Benjamin thank you